Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
Oliver Darren is speaking at a cyber
security conference in Belfast about the
threat to the UK of Russian cyber
attacks we're just going to listen in
briefly
tools that we used to only see in a
handful of State actors and which can
cause serious damage
so it's something we're taking very
seriously and to which we are responding
with our International partners
meanwhile cybercrime is estimated to
cost the UK billions of pounds each year
according to new figures published today
32 percent of UK businesses and
Charities suffered a cyber breach or
attack in the past year that is a third
of our businesses
and ransomware continues to run rampant
and as prime minister as President Biden
rightly recognized a few weeks ago
thanks to its scale and its impact
ransomware is no longer just a crime
it's a national security threat
and our response needs to reflect the
severity of that threat
these are attacks on our citizens
our businesses and our democracy
they are an attempt to undermine our
society and we are determined to stop
them with your help
in the UK we grasp the need for Urgent
action early and we've been doing a lot
over the past few years to strengthen
our cyber defenses
we have published the national cyber
strategy and we have a new and effective
cyber sanctions regime which we recently
used for the first time against a group
of Russian cyber criminals as part of a
joint campaign with the United States
and we're working closely with
International Partners to tackle the
proliferation of sophisticated
commercial cyber tools
at the same time the government itself
continues to face a range of attacks
including ransomware and Espionage and
so we are constantly looking to
strengthen our cyber defenses
and as part of that today I can announce
that we are launching gov ashore a
transformational new Cyber regime for
the whole of government Governor Shaw
will be rolled out across Whitehall it
will be used to assess every
Department's cyber Health on an annual
basis against stringent new measures so
that government can better identify the
risks we face and make sure we are
protecting systems that help us run
Public Services
so with each day as the threat evolves
so does our response
but a new adversary has emerged
over the last 18 months the national
cyber security Center has seen the rise
of several Russian aligned groups
sympathetic to Putin's invasion of
Ukraine
now these are Fringe State threats the
Cyber equivalent of the Wagner group
and initially those groups focus their
attacks on Ukraine and the surrounding
region
but recently they have begun to turn
their attention to the United Kingdom
and its allies
they are now seeking opportunities to
compromise our critical National
infrastructure
we have experienced attempted attacks in
the past
but these groups operate differently
instead of seeking to profit or spy on
us
their primary motive is to disrupt or
destroy our infrastructure
these adversaries are ideologically
motivated rather than financially
motivated
secondly
through these perpetrators though these
perpetrators are aligned to National
actors crucially they're often not
controlled by those foreign States
that makes them more opportunistic and
less likely to show restraint
together those factors make the current
situation particularly concerning
and so today I can confirm that the
national cyber security Center is
issuing an official alert to operators
of our critical National infrastructure
to highlight the risk they currently
face
that alert is now live on the ncsc's
website along with a number of
recommended actions that operators
should follow right now to increase
their resilience and help defend our
infrastructure against these attacks
disclosing this threat is not something
we do likely
this is an unprecedented warning for
business we have never publicly
highlighted the threat from these kinds
of groups attempting such attacks before
and I should stress that we do not think
that they currently have the capability
to cause widespread damage to our
infrastructure in the United Kingdom
but we do believe it is necessary at
this point of time if we want companies
to understand the threat they currently
face
and to take action to defend themselves
and the country against such attacks
this approach fits with that wider
National Security strategy
and last year
when we saw that Russian forces were
gathering at the Ukrainian border we
Declassified the information to let the
world see what they were doing
today with cyber threats you will
increasingly see us say what we are
seeing
we won't allow these groups to stay in
the shadows we're shining a light on
these threats because we need to work
together to strengthen our defenses
that means that businesses need to see
the threats clearly too
and over the last few years we've done
lots of things to make it easier for
businesses to secure themselves
so there we go that was Oliver Dowden
who's the chancellor of the duchy of
Lancaster he is also of course the
National Security and investment
Minister saying that in the last few
minutes the UK facing unprecedented
threats from Russian aligned entities a
clearly very significant intervention
there